ذلك تحدثنا اكثر اكثر من جو خضار كارمن
سلطات الطوارئ المواليه لروسيا تقول ان
المياه غمرت اربعه الاف بل اربعه عشر الف
منزلا وتم اجلاء اكثر من 4000 شخص حتى
الان
نعمان هي كارثه فعليه هكذا تتعامل معها
روسيا وتوصفها وتوصف بعض المدن والقرى
المحيطه بسديكا بالمنكوبه ولكن في اخر
المعطيات التي وردتنا الان السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا تتحدث عن خمسه
قتله
وواحد واربعون شخصا نقل الى المستشفيات
لتلقي العلاج جراء الفيضانات التي اصابت
المنطقه المحيطه
ليس فقط هذه المدينه التي يقع فيها السد
ولكن ايضا المدن المحيطه بها نذكر جيدا ان
صورا ومقاطع مصوره نشرت لغمرك عدد كبير من
المباني السكنيه تحدثت سلطات الطوارئ عن
14000 مبنى يعني غرقت بالمياه وكانت
السلطات المحليه تحدثت عن ان مستوى منسوب
المياه تجاوز الاثني عشر مترا تحدثت اليوم
السلطات صبيحه هذا اليوم عن تراجعي منسوب
هذه المياه ولكن وفق تقديراتها الاوليه
تشير الى ان تراجع المنسوب وانحسار منسوب
هذه المياه التي انتشرت بشكل كبير بعد
تفجير السد قد يحتاج الى اسبوع وربما اكثر
وفق المعطيات التي تتوالى وتردون من تلك
المنطقه التي كما اشرت وصفت بالمنكوبه
هناك التحديات جمه امام السلطات المحليه
تتجلى في اجلاء واستمرار عمليات الاجلاء
في تلك المنطقه تنشر مقاطع مصوره وصورا
لمتطوعين يحاولون اجلاء السكان في تلك
المنطقه تتحدث عن اعاده التيار الكهربائي
اليها ومد المياه ولكن المشكله اليوم اولا
في احصاء الخسائر وفي التعامل مع حجم
الخسائر البالغه نذكر جيدا ان هذه المنطقه
منطقه زراعيه وهناك هكتارات من الاراضي
الزراعيه اتلفت بشكل كامل وخسائرها بطبيعه
الحال ست على الجانب الغذائي وعلى الامن
الغذائي ليس فقط لجنوب اوكرانيا ولكن هناك
تحذيرات عالميه ودوليه في هذا الاطار ايضا
هناك تحذيرات مرتبطه كانت بمحطه
من المسؤولين الروس المرتبطين بهذه المحطه
على ان ايكون السيناريوهات مطروحه وعلى
الرغم من تناقص وتراجع منسوب المياه
المسؤوله عن تبريد المفاعلات ولكن الامر
تحت السيطره لغايه هذه اللحظه ارتباطا بما
يجري في نوفاكاخوفكا بطبيعه الحال في
خرسون تراجعت العمليات وتوقفت يمكن القول
بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه ولكن السلطات
المحليه تتحدث عن قصف اوكراني مستمر للضفه
التي تتواجد عليها القوات الروسيه ولكن
عثمان مقاطعه اخرى متاخمه لخرسون هي
مقاطعه
لعمليات عسكريه مشدده تحدثت عدد من
المواقع العسكريه الروسيه ان ليله امس
شهدت معارك ضاريه بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه فيزا بروجيا وقالت ان القوات
الروسيه استطاعت سطات كل هذه الهجمات في
هذه المقاطعه الجنوبيه ايضا تحدثت المواقع
العسكريه عن هجمات مكثفه شماليه ضخمه
واكدت ان القوات الروسيه ايضا تصطادت لهذه
المحاوله اليوم رابط ما يجري في
نوفاكاخوفكا يرى فيه المحللون انه واصابع
الاتهام الموجه باتجاه اوكرانيا ينطلقون
من انها محاوله
لردع القوات الروسيه التي كانت تحضر هجمات
باتجاه الضفه الاخرى وباتجاه المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها اوكرانيا ويدللون على ذلك
عثمان انطلاقا من ان الدفاعات التي كانت
وضعتها روسيا عند الضفه التي تسيطر عليها
كلها بالغرقت بفعل هذا الفيضان شكرا جزيلا
لكما كان من جو خضر من دنيات